but let me let me talk to you about uh
the issue i've had with the cops uh you
know my concerns and and discontent is
you know kovit after uh the george floyd
riots you know i was very much like if
there's one thing i think
any any person can agree on that police
should be doing is stopping rioting
stopping direct crime against
individuals violent crime and things
like that you want to argue about drugs
being legal all the libertarian stuff
it's like okay okay we'll have a debate
about that but we all agree like if
people are running around burning down
buildings we would appreciate a police
force to be like hey stop doing that
the problem is
and there's reasons behind this but for
one we saw in new york cops were
standing down we saw in many of these
circumstances cops standing down we know
why as you were mentioning it's too
dangerous and they have no support from
the community so i'm not gonna you know
go in and cheer on the people who live
in new york city for voting for and
supporting the problems they're causing
themselves but when i saw the police
even local sheriffs going to cafe owners
and salon owners and arresting them or
finding them or shutting down their
businesses over covid i was like nah you
lost me
you know i i can come out all day and
say
that uh the regular working-class cop
you know is not a racist that those are
media lies and narratives these stories
are are few and far between their rare
circumstances but man the stuff we saw
around police shutting down people's
livelihood lively this was everywhere
you had attila's gym
cops showed up shut them down even
arrested i think one guy got arrested
the government issued all these fines
and the police are the ones backing it
up in north jersey you had a woman whose
store was closed and she was live
streaming her products cops showed up
and shut her down you had a sheriff's
department in minnesota chase a woman or
or uh
i was it was an iowa department i
believe apprehend a woman
because she had opened her coffee house
during lockdown and with a smile on
their face they they they grabbed these
people with and that blows my mind how
how is that and you know explain to me
that mindset that you could be a cop and
be like how dare this lady do someone's
hair i'm gonna arrest her that to me is
insane it is insane i think
man it's
it's tough because i don't i don't want
to bash the cops but you could look on
my twitter feed from months ago when
this was happening and i said the same
thing i said
guys you're being played
they are using you as their henchmen and
you're being played you've got to do the
right thing everybody stand down
and but i also think there's got to be
some responsibility on the other side
too for the people that want to make a
point
like when you go into a restaurant
that's private and they go
hey i've gotta i've gotta abide by this
or the police will come in and find me
if i don't and they're like screw that i
want my food but i can't because you're
not you're not abiding by this even
though it's an unlawful mandate i agree
with that
but neither should have fear of serving
or getting food
but because of our government
they're enforcing these mandates that
are unconstitutional and then
both of them are this this owner is in
fear of losing his livelihood
this guy's trying to prove a point that
i don't have to follow these illegal
mandates and then the cop comes in
you know and he probably agrees with
both of them honestly and is like man
these are stupid but what am i supposed
to do here if i don't do this my body
cam's on now i'm going to lose my job
and my livelihood
and he should
yeah i mean absolutely i mean if you're
going to take a stand if you're going to
sacrifice you've got to do it i mean but
they can't if they all stood up
and said no they couldn't fire them all
right i don't i'm not saying the cops
should be fired uh technically i'm
saying the cop should
uh gladly recognize the system is broken
you've become the villain if you know
and people say to me you don't
understand you you need your job you got
to pay your bills and my my response is
like i totally get it
you know people don't seem to understand
because they're like oh look how
successful you are tim uh it's easy for
you to say and i'm like
i've always said it even when i was
broke it's what leads me to the point of
success and i'm unwilling to to
compromise with the with with this kind
of you know amoral behavior or
illegality at the very least i could
recognize the cop
starting you know these officers and
many have planning their exodus from
these departments for other areas look
what florida said florida we had
billboards out not out here where were
they i think there was one out here
actually billboards in like the dc area
saying become a police officer in
florida now hiring benefits yeah florida
where we have your back
yeah yeah well and they said we got no
mandates you don't got to do this stuff
don't have to do it i think people need
to realize you're not trapped in this
one job but what i wish my point being
i agree with the no mandates i was a
push the limit on not wearing a mask i'm
not vast i'm not anti-vaccine i'm not
anti-vaccine i can't lie and say you are
you know yeah whatever uh
yeah anything that you disagree with you
get hammered but uh so i'm not vaxxed i
hardly ever wore a mask unless i'm
flying just because i gotta get
somewhere and maybe that's hypocritical
of me too but
the point is
go make your statement go in there have
the police called on you but when they
come there instead of giving the cop a
hard time to go you've made your point
right if you want to pick it outside
do it
i agree with that actually but they
really don't want that hamburger they
want to make a point and i get it
but do it where you're not harming the
other people that kind of agree with you
you know we have a we have a lesson in
skateboarding when we're little it's uh
younger if when you're skateboarding in
the streets meaning you're going to
corporate buildings or you're loading
docks behind you know warehouses
you can skate and as soon as you see a
security guard you leave yeah when the
security guard walks up and says hey you
can't skate here go sorry about that and
you leave and then when he leaves you
come back you come right back yeah well
i i would i would not advocate for
immediately coming back if you're told
you're trespassing and trespassing you
shouldn't trespass but the point is that
if you leave right away you don't blow
up the spot as we would call it meaning
other people have heard about it they
might end up showing up we've had kids
you know i remember this man they
smashed a window because security guard
told them to leave and i'm like they
just ruin everything for everybody so
now you'll never be able to come back
here because they'll set up something
where you can't so you know i think
about this and i'm like imagine going
into a restaurant and
they say you can't be in here there's a
mandate and they say i'm not leaving
because you're discriminating against me
and they say well i'm gonna call the
police say okay call the police in every
circumstance the cops have showed up and
said you've been informed you're
trespassing you're being warned to leave
at that point you can be like okay walk
out the front door wait for the cops to
go walk back in and say i want a
cheeseburger and that causes a bigger
problem than having some cop arrest you
and then inconvenience inconveniencing
yourself and if you look at the bigger
picture here's what this has done now
this has taken
we've already had a divided country
right
in 2020 we were pretty
you had this group in this group that
believed two different things cops bad
cops good
now what they've done is they've
subdivided the good cop part because
they're using them to enforce laws on
people that support the cops but now the
cops have to stand up to those people
and now they're mad at the cops so now
the left wins again because they've
broken us even more and we're weaker in
in new york
they had 27 police officers defending
what was an illegal painting in the
street bill de blasio
seized taxpayer funds illegally to paint
black lives matter in front of trump's
building and 27 cops with smiles on
their faces
guarded that illegal act i wouldn't be
able to do it no now look i i understand
these are cops who live in new york city
so they're probably democrats
and then you but but surprising to me
it's like how could you live in a city
where the people who vote for the
politicians who appoint the the the
commissioner or the chief of police and
then hire these these other cops you're
the villain in this whole story to
everyone right the cops defending the
black lives matter mural are villains to
the left already and for defending the
illegal actions of the mayor they're
villains to the right
i i you got to be i
it takes a special kind of resolve to
decide that you want to be hated by
everybody and but but truth be told it's
not always the wrong choice sometimes
being hit by everybody is the right
thing to do in this instance i don't
think so a challenge i guess is
you know
people people it's hard to just quit
your job when you got a mortgage when
you got kids and that's the the the
that's the news man well they get you
it's it's no different than what what i
was talking about a few minutes ago with
all the government subsidies they get
you trapped
and you can't do anything you know
unless you take a leap of faith or you
get a good opportunity i mean they get
you trapped there too this is
it's it's sad and it's scary because
it's just
slavery democrats are pushing uh
policies
that put more people in positions where
they can't leave their jobs and are
desperate
and that's what it is that's the boot on
your neck yeah so when you got what was
it joe biden was talking about this
policy for urbanizing the suburbs i
don't know if you saw this one the idea
was to build more trains going into the
suburbs to do ban single single housing
development things like that oh yes
that would create
more desperation and destitution which
they then can manipulate by saying you
can't quit your job you could only
afford to live in this extremely high
cost of living area on with loans and
then if you lose your job you can't pay
off your loans and then we're gonna come
for your kids and people say okay okay
you got me i'll enforce whatever you say
and there it is if everyone just said no
these problems would be solved instantly
what if i just took my mortgage out as a
student loan will the government forgive
it
well they're not doing that that's
what's funny all the other progressives
were like yeah but i didn't forgive
student loans and he was like nah yeah i
need to take those billions and send
them to the middle east well to be fair
you can you can file bankruptcy
uh and get a lot of your debt you know
wiped but not for student loans yeah so
if you get student loans i'm not a fan
of the student loan system i think i
worked three jobs in college so i don't
feel sorry for them but i do i do think
personally we can we can do something
about the interest rates oh yeah yeah i
would agree on the interest that's why
everybody agrees or
how come colleges can increase their
percentage of tuition every year so much
i mean it just keeps climbing because
they want you to be an indentured
servant because when you've got student
loans you can't quit your job you can't
file bankruptcy on student loans they
got you locked up and you don't even
realize they got you locked up but a lot
of people are starting to realize it now
here's what else happens
they use that
to once again manipulate those they've
already locked into a denture and
servitude with ridiculous we'll forgive
your student loans vote for us and then
what happens biden's like no just
kidding just switch yeah it would be
nice if donald trump said we're going to
deal he did suspend loans i believe
during coven i think i think donald
trump if he gets elected i think there
should be some kind of executive action
because these are these are federal
loans i think they have the authority to
do this i'm not sure just say interest
rates shut down right get back what you
what you borrowed yeah it's kind of like
the thing earlier with the you know
getting people back on their feet right
they don't have to get interest on them
just get your money back
you borrowed it you use the money you
got to pay it back because a lot of
those loans weren't just for school they
got that that cost of living stuff too
they could buy food pay for their
apartments whatever else you got to pay
it all back yeah if they gave you 50
grand i think you got to pay it back and
we should discuss how that inflation
works into that however you know i know
people who uh have taken out like twenty
thousand loans and now they own forty
and they've already paid back for it and
this is like saying yeah these stories
are insane right so i i think you gotta
a lot of the i i think the populist
right understands all of this i think
conservative inc often doesn't you know
the more like establishment not so much
establishment but a lot of these uh
conservatives say like yeah you're those
are your responsibility you took out the
loans you signed the contract and i'm
like that's true i agree with that i
don't agree with making someone pay back
40 grand on a 17 000 loan that's insane
yeah now we're getting to the point
where the point of school loans and the
reason you can't be declaring bankruptcy
in my opinion or what i thought was that
we're going to help kickstart your life
to get you a good skill set good career
crippling them so they can't have
families and buy houses it's just bad
for everybody the government turn into
the mafia yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it'll
never get me paid off yeah well and of
course these uh these loans are
subsidized by the government the entire
idea is they're going to guarantee the
student loans and that's only resulted
in colleges raising tuition costs and
now you have instances where someone
will borrow twenty thousand they'll end
up paying back forty thousand you just
have to ask the question is it really a
productive use of economic resources to
have entire groups of people whose
career is to live off of the interest
of loans that were lent out prior that
have already been more than paid back is
that really the best use of
human will power and thought and labor
for someone to just be in a position
where they're living off of interest
think about it i don't think so
we we're wondering why it is that a
police officer is going to arrest
someone who owns a salon and that's why
and if you are an authoritarian in
government the last thing you want is
for police officers especially to say
men of good conscience do not follow
unjust orders but when they say we'll
take your kids we'll take your house and
you'll be on the street and you'll see
how quickly people are willing to bend
over backwards yeah it will it and also
i mean it makes sense again given the
way inflation works to charge some level
of interest on a loan but you know once
it's once you're paying back
significantly significantly more than
you took out i think it's it's pretty
criminal and also uh you know when you
look at real estate yeah i mean a lot of
people are in debt because they're
paying off a mortgage mortgage but
they're building equity you look at
these people who have way overpaid for
these degrees that are really useless
and for someone's you know for these
banks to get to be getting rich off of
this government policy is just a
redistribution of wealth from taxpayers
and from these young people who took
loans out to the big banks i don't i
just don't see how conservatives could
consider that to be acceptable it's big
government intervening on behalf of
business and on behalf of the banks to
protect their profits or give them more
what's the problem big government that
hands them way too much
i think we need a very small federal
government and it's yeah they they're
trying to control everything but but i
do think there's something the tides
have turned i do think that
freedom
honesty
and
integrity
i think that's winning a lot of these
these moral values
are probably probably viewed as
conservative because i don't know if
you've ever looked at jonathan heights
moral foundations research no
there's six moral foundations
the left has two care and fairness
so they don't have uh uh authority they
don't have loyalty they don't have
purity and they don't have liberty those
are the other i believe those are the
other ones i could be making mistakes
but i'm pretty sure that's it
conservative conservatives have all of
them all six in in fairly equal amounts
my favorite point here is that
libertarians have one
just liberty liberty like seriously
libertarians like uh when they they
initially had five moral foundations
then realized something was missing
because some some people had nothing and
they're like what is this and it was
like oh because they only care about
people being allowed to do their own
thing and be left alone
libertarians
you know they they there was a uh
who was it someone got booed for saying
that uh you should be allowed to sell
drugs peterson yeah
gary johnson tweeted like the
libertarian party of new hampshire said
like i know bring back child labor maybe
it was gary johnson who was booed i
don't maybe it wasn't austin peterson i
need to double check the libertarian
party of new hampshire said you know we
legalized child labor yeah and gary
johnson was like no no like this is not
what we need
and that's like people are
you see the slippery slope because now
with the
you know trying to teach these
kindergartners about
transsexuals and sex period that it's
it's
where does it stop where do you draw the
line and go okay this is it no more well
that's a whole other conversation right
yeah but uh you know the point i'm
bringing up with the moral foundations
is that
a lot of the things that
we we want to be winning
are more tip are typical of
conservatives like
like loyalty
and purity is another more foundation
purity meaning like you don't want
children being
abused or exposed but this is not a
moral foundation that exists among the
left for the most part so it's typically
conservative but my point was uh i think
these moral foundations are starting to
win and i think there's a lot to do with
the internet with uh podcasts the
ability of people to to form communities
online
but what needs to happen more of which
is happening is people standing up
speaking up and just standing firm and
saying you know i'm not going to do
something that is that is a violation of
these foundations because what i will
tell you is
if the moral foundations the six that
are winning
uh
indicate that conservatives tend to be
winning uh and conservative isn't
necessarily the right answer because
libertarian post-liberal conservative
but it just means that ideas like
loyalty are winning
that's not with that not being on the
left you can understand why they're why
the left is angry about it and why the
left would force or convince a
conservative or libertarian to abandon a
moral foundation for personal gain
so if you're a conservative and you have
all of the moral foundations and loyalty
is something that's important to you and
then you see something that is an
egregious violation of say loyalty to
the country
that doesn't mean blind loyalty it means
like we're going to stand by and support
you know our our troops we're going to
stand by and support our law enforcement
who are genuinely trying again not
blindly right legitimately
the left would say no don't do that
don't be loyal to your community
when when when we say with the boot on
your neck you're not allowed to sell
coffee
we want you to abandon your moral
foundations and do what we want because
we have none and because of the way
they've put the boot down you've got
cops who are like yes sir whatever you
say and that's horrifying thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you